Millie I have a question what he has
well what do you like to watch around
7:00 or 7:30 at night a little program
called
David tonight
[Music]
I know you were fear nothing I said
nothing but I was scared I mean the guy
was sort of in the suit so I saw the guy
but it's this horribly disfigured thing
with long otherworldly live David up and
the face does something that you never
want some face to do I'm not very scared
of things like that I mean I'm scared of
like ghosts and stuff but monsters they
don't really big slimy each like monster
has that little like oh wait scratches
your eye bites you so you don't really
know what it's finished
you don't mean that's like you know it's
gonna hurt you don't know how it's gonna
hurt so like you know I like that so cuz
when I you know when I saw shadows I run
out of school and I run it was like oh
hi nice to meet you
I mean honestly the best thing about the
monster though is how little you see it
sort of in the beginning you know it's
like those Neil burger movies with jaws
where it's like you you just see the fin
it's not scary it's got that horrid see
we had it's got that horror to it but it
is scary but it's not just skin no it's
not just its comedic that's true it's
like a great character piece it has
great characters that has great scenes
at it's great dialogue masturbating and
then like there's monsters too and
there's like other realities and and so
that's like really exciting because I
love both those genres you know and it's
not just one or the other
I think it's unlike anything else I've
ever seen
[Music]